I expected it to derail my career and it
did I I have never been like a tenured
faculty member anywhere I've been a
professor now I'm a visiting scientist
and I love it but it because it when I
first started working on it it was so
controversial that nobody wanted to
touch it I couldn't even get I couldn't
even get an article published on it
except for this little magazine
associated with the the bakken library
and museum of electricity in life which
is out in Minneapolis and even they
later you began to think better of it
but it was too late by then of course
once you publish publish but then after
working on it on the thing for like well
I guess was more than 20 years it came
out in 1999 which turned out to be the
perfect year for it although I mean I
didn't know that I couldn't have but you
know that's when I finished it and it
came it came out and people just went
bonkers over it it was it even did a law
and order special victims unit thing
with with a little vignette of from my
book and I was like it's not what an
historian expects but it's been it's
been quite a trip and now there's been a
movie and a play which is a running
right right now at the Lyceum and I'm
told scouts honor a puppet musical
you're going to laugh at me because what
I thought was going to happen was that
my colleagues would talk about it a lot
and it would be reviewed in the
scholarly journals and that that's all I
expected I thought maybe a few people
might use it as a textbook but actually
it's used as a textbook in about 150
colleges and universities around the
world it's been translated now I think
it's now in three languages and people
just loved my hypothesis and that's all
it is really as a hypothesis that that
women were treated with massage for this
disease hysteria which has supposedly
existed since the time of Hippocrates
450 BC and that the vibrator was
invented to treat this disease well
people just thought this was such a cool
idea that people believe it that it's
like a fact and I'm like it's a
hypothesis that I'm posits but doesn't
matter you know if people like it so
much they don't want to hear any doubts
about it eventually somebody will sit
down and say now maybe there's another
way to interpret these data but in the
meantime I'm really kind of enjoying all
it's such a book it's as you can imagine